- What the heck is ketogenic diet?
- [Narrator] Quickly lose weight.
- Fats with benefits.
- Satiates your appetite.
- She chose this.
- He chose this.
- [Reporter] Butter is good.
- Explain yourself.
- The ketogenic diet,
let's break down what
all this hype is about.
I'm gonna tell you what it is,
briefly how it works,
and discuss some of the claims
they're most commonly made on the subject.
Let's get started.
(upbeat music)
Before we get into the ketogenic diet,
let's break down some very
simple nutrition basics.
There're three major macronutrient groups
that we're gonna be paying attention to:
proteins, fats, and carbs.
These are nutrients that you
find in the foods you eat
every single day.
This standard American diet
consists of 35% of fats,
15% of proteins, and 50% of carbs.
Now if you're looking at ketogenic diet,
the numbers are quite
different with 75% being fats,
20% being proteins, and
only 5% being carbs.
Think about that, that's
10 times less carbs
than in an standard American diet.
Let's say you switch
from your standard diet
to a ketogenic diet, what
happens inside of your body?
Your body deals with this
very low carb consumption
in two ways: first, it enters
a state called ketosis,
which shifts your body's energy
source to a primarily fats.
Which basically means
that it breaks down fats
into something known as
ketones, hence ketosis,
and then uses those for energy.
Simply put, your body begins to burn fat
as its primary energy source,
and moves away from glucose,
which is a carbohydrate.
The process of going into
ketosis does take a few days,
and during those days,
people experience some
adverse side effects:
brain fog, irritability,
nausea, GI discomfort.
Some people label this the "Keto Flu."
- I don't feel so good.
- The second process your
body uses is gluconeogenesis,
which sounds scary, but it's really not.
All it is is your body creating glucose
because now all cells can
function on fats alone.
Fun fact here, for survival purposes,
you don't need to consume any carbs
as long as you're getting
enough fats and proteins.
Now where did all of this hype
for the ketogenic diet come from?
Let's take a look at the claims
and find out what's true,
and what's not.
Claim number one,
the ketogenic diet is
good for weight loss.
Yeah, the ketogenic diet
is good for weight loss,
and this happens through
two important mechanisms.
First, since you're using fats
as your primary energy source,
you're burning a lot of stored fat.
Second, because fat is very
satiating, makes you feel full,
when you eat a high fat content meal,
you actually don't want to eat as much.
Therefore, you limit the
amount of calories you take in
throughout the day.
A lot of people are surprised that
when they start the ketogenic
diet, that they lose weight
very quickly, but that's
a little misleading
because the majority of
the weight loss initially
comes from water loss, not fat loss.
For those of you seeking
long-term weight loss,
the ketogenic diet is
not super sustainable.
It's graduation day, all
your friends are going to get
ice cream, some of them are getting
a cookies and cream milkshakes.
And you can't have any cause
you on a ketogenic diet,
that's crazy.
You have to be super vigilant
when you're on a ketogenic diet
because carbs have this
nasty habit of just
sneaking into your foods.
Ketchup, high carb food.
Apples, bananas, cookies
and cream milkshakes,
well, I just love cookies
and cream milkshakes.
And so much for having a
salivatory drink with your friends,
no to alcohol.
Claim number two, the ketogenic
diet is good for the brain.
The truth of the matter is, the
jury's still out on this one
because science hasn't
given us the answer.
The research on this area just
hasn't been completed yet.
Anecdotally, some people
say they feel more focused
or sharper when on a ketogenic diet,
but I've also heard patients
of mine that they feel
foggier, and that Keto Flu
stays with them much longer
than anticipated.
So I don't like using
anecdotes as reasons why
a certain diet is good or not.
I need quality research,
which I just don't have.
Claim number three, a keto
diet prevents, or manages,
many chronic diseases.
This is a yes and no answer,
where a keto diet really shines
is in Type II Diabetes.
Because when you have Type II Diabetes,
you have insulin sensitivity issues,
you have high sugar content in the blood,
and research has shown over and over again
that the ketogenic diet
for Type II Diabetes works.
- Yes!
- We have to talk about Childhood Epilepsy
because that's where the keto diet
actually got its roots.
We can actually prescribe the
ketogenic diet to children
who have refractory epileptic seizures,
and what we find is once they
get into a state of ketosis,
they have a decreased
frequency of these seizures.
It works, it's proven, it's
evidence-based science.
The ketogenic diet has shown some promise
in the field of oncology, aka cancer.
It's not ready to be a prime
time cancer treatment just yet,
and the research doesn't fully support it
to be a preventive measure
for developing cancer.
But what we do know is
that some promises there,
and more research needs to be done.
Some harms that can stem from
following a ketogenic diet:
nutritional deficiencies from
cutting out large groups,
and increase in your
"bad" LDL cholesterol,
kidney issues, bone issues,
and even the increase of
some certain cancers when
you're overeating foods like
processed or red meat.
My final thoughts on the keto diet,
I think it's a good diet for weight loss,
I think it's better for
short-term weight loss
than long-term weight loss.
So if you have a wedding that
you're getting ready for,
or some kind of big event that's upcoming,
and you're otherwise healthy,
I don't think it's a bad diet to go along.
The fact that the diet is
very difficult to adhere to
because of how much you
have to drastically change
your eating patterns of the
possible adverse effects
that can come from following the diet,
and frankly, from the lack of knowledge,
and the lack of research we
have on its long-term effects,
all put into question and
really encourage me to
not recommend this diet to
the majority of my patients
and to you at home.
I read in the comments
that some of you want me to
try the keto diet.
If we get this video to 20,000 likes,
I will try the keto diet,
and I will take you on
the journey along with me.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
We have to talk about Childhood Epilepsy
because that's where the keto
diet actually got its roots,
found its roots, began its roots?
I fucking hate itchy nose syndrome.
I don't know how to do these,
do I do it the whole time?
I said "Keto Flu," the
"Keto Flu." (laughs)
(knuckles knocking the table)
Settle down there,
she's like where did he
just pops into frame.
(upbeat music)